let's start by looking at some of those
measures that were talked to just a
moment ago tehnology joints so a new
digital services tax on technology Jones
will see just how much that raises in a
second to get some perspective on how
big that is income tax the personal tax
allowance rising a year earlier than
expected in the NHS this twenty point
five billion pounds actually put more
than that when you look at the end of
the forecast horizon we found out just
how the Chancellor's paying for that
let's look at a few more measures as
well push those across PFI the end of
PFI and the DPF to its successor
universal credit more money for
universal credit and according to the
resolution foundation they are talking
about the fact that universal credit is
now actually more generous than tax
credits than the benefit system that
preceded it so a big moment there you
will just a moment there an austerity
the Chancellor's saying that this budget
ends austerity does that actually tally
with what we've seen from these numbers
well let's start by just having a look
at those new policies that we've seen
the new tech tech tax that's come in how
much money does this actually raise well
you can see here these arrows show you
money coming in to the Exchequer and
just look at these numbers you're
talking about 400 million pounds a year
how significant is that compared with
other taxes other measures that we've
learnt about today well let's put it in
perspective by comparing it with the NHS
tax or the NHS giveaway rather you can
see these numbers are far bigger we're
talking about billions of pounds and not
just billions of pounds tens of billions
of pounds by 2023 27 point six billion
pounds so you do get a sense of just how
small this tech tax income in comparison
with the big taxes with the big
giveaways that we've heard about today
and actually when you look at the total
policy decisions say the amount that the
money of money that the government is
actually spending so coming out of the
exchage it this is big stuff this was a
big giveaway budget one of the biggest
that we've seen in some years largely
though because of the NHS pledged that
the Prime Minister made earlier on this
year and how is the Chancellor actually
financing this well the short answer is
with a bit more of this borrowing this
chart shows you just how much the
government was expected to borrow at the
time of the spring statement each of
these bars the higher they are the more
than
borrowing and actually it turns out that
tax revenues came in a bit better than
expected this year so in this year look
there's a cut in the borrowing forecast
now there's a clue as to what happened
next when you look at the following
lines and notice that each of the